on the loss of their mother who sadly
passed away yesterday our thoughts are
with them and their whole family at this
most difficult of times
mr speaker with permission i'd like to
make a statement on the pandemic and our
autumn and winter plan to manage the
risk of covid19
over the past few months we've been
making progress down the road to
recovery carefully and cautiously moving
closer to normal life
and as we do this we've been working
hard to strengthen our defenses against
this deadly virus
we've been continuing the rollout of our
vaccination program with 81 of people
over the age of 16 having had the
protection of both doses we've expanded
our testing capacity yet further opening
a new mega lab in lemington spa
and we've continued supporting research
into long covid taking our total
investment to 50 million pounds
thanks to this determined effort
we've made some major steps forward
the link between cases hospitalizations
and deaths has weakened significantly
since the start of the pandemic and
deaths from covert 19 have been
mercifully low compared to previous
waves
but we must be vigilant as autumn and
winter are favorable conditions for
covet 19 and other seasonal viruses
children have returned to school more
and more people are returning to work
the changing weather means that there
will be more people perhaps spending
time indoors
and there's likely to be a lot of
non-covered demand on the nhs including
flu a norovirus
today
keeping our commitment to this house i'd
like to provide an update on our review
of preparedness for autumn and winter
the plan shows how we'll give this
nation the best possible chance of
living with kovid without the need for
stringent social and economic
restrictions
there are five pillars to this plan mr
speaker
first
further strengthening our pharmaceutical
defenses like vaccines
the latest statistics from the ons show
that almost 99 of covert 19 deaths in
the first half of this year were people
who had not received both doses of a
covid19 vaccine
this shows the importance of our
vaccination program and by extending
this program further we can protect even
more people almost 6 million people over
the age of 16 remain unvaccinated in the
uk
and the more people that are
unvaccinated the larger the holes in our
collective defenses
so we'll renew our efforts to maximize
uptake amongst those that are eligible
but have not yet for whatever reason
taken up the offer
next
we've been planning our booster doses
too
like with many other vaccines there's
evidence that the protection offered by
covert 19 vaccine reduces over time
particularly older people who are
greater risk
and so booster doses are an important
way of keeping the virus under control
for the long term
this morning we published the jcvi's
advice on a booster program
they've recommended that people who were
vaccinated in phase one that is priority
groups one to nine should be offered a
booster vaccine
that this vaccine should be offered no
earlier than six months after the
completion of the primary vaccine course
and that as far as possible the booster
program should be deployed in the same
order as phase one
i can confirm that i have accepted the
jcvi's advice and that the nhs is
preparing to offer booster doses from
next week
the nhs will contact people at the right
time and nobody needs to come forward at
this point
this this booster program it will
protect the most vulnerable through the
winter months and strengthen our wall of
defense even further
as well as this
we'll be extending the offer of a
covered 19 vaccine to even more people
as the minister for covert 19 vaccine
deployment announced yesterday in the
house and thank you mr speaker for
allowing him to make that statement
yesterday
all young people aged 16 to 17 in
england have already been offered a dose
of a covert 19 vaccine to give them the
protection
as they return to school
and yesterday the uk's chief medical
officers unanimously recommended making
a universal offer of a first dose of a
vaccine to people aged between the two
ages of 12 and 15.
the government has accepted this
recommendation too and will move with
urgency to put this into action
we're also seeing great advances in the
use of antivirals and therapeutics
several covert 19 treatments are already
available through the nhs and our
antivirus task force is leading the
search for breakthroughs in anti-virals
which have so much more potential to
offer
second mr speaker
testing
tracing and self-isolation have been
another vital defense
over the autumn and winter pcr testing
for those with covert 19 symptoms and
contacts of confirmed cases will
continue to be available free of charge
regular asymptomatic testing
which identifies currently around a
quarter of all reported cases
will also continue in the coming months
with a focus on those who are not fully
vaccinated perhaps those in education or
in other higher risk settings
and contact tracing will continue
through the nhs test and trace system
we don't want people to face hardship
for as they carry out their duty to
self-isolate so for those that are still
required to self-isolate will keep
offering practical and financial support
to people who are eligible and need
assistance and will review these
regulations and this support by the end
of march 2022
our third pillar mr speaker is that
we're supporting the nhs and social care
last week i announced a 5.4 billion
pound injection for the nhs to support
the kobit 19 response over the next six
months
including one billion pounds extra to
tackle the elective backlog caused by
covert 19.
we've also launched a consultation on
protecting vulnerable patients by making
covid19 and flu vaccinations a condition
of deployment for frontline healthcare
staff and why the
wider social care workers in england
we're already making this a condition of
deployment for people in cqc registered
adult care homes and although we are
keeping an open mind and we won't be
making a final decision until we fully
consider the results of the consultation
i believe that it is highly likely that
frontline nhs staff and those working in
wider social care settings will also
have to be vaccinated to protect those
that are around them and that this will
be an important step in protecting those
at greatest risk
fourth mr speaker we'll be we'll keep
encouraging people to take steps to keep
seasonal illnesses at bay including flu
and cope 19.
the best step that we can all take is to
get vaccinations for covid19 and flu if
we're eligible
and so along with our covert 19
vaccination program the next few months
we'll see the largest ever flu
vaccination campaign this country has
ever seen
our plan also sets out a number of
changes we can all make to our daily
routines like meeting outdoors where
possible or if you need to be indoors
trying to let in fresh air wearing a
face mask in crowded and enclosed spaces
where you can come into contact with
people that you don't normally meet
and
and mr speaker
our fifth pillar
is how we'll look beyond our shores and
pursue an international approach last
week i attended a g20 health ministers
meeting and i met counterparts from
across the world and i talked about the
part that we'll be playing to lead the
global effort to accelerate access to
vaccines to therapeutics and to
diagnostics
and as we do this we'll maintain our
strong defenses at the border allowing
us to identify and to respond to
variants of concern
it's these defenses and the progress of
vaccination campaigns both here and
abroad that have allowed us to manage
the risks and to start carefully
reopening international travel once
again
we've already relaxed the rules for
fully vaccinated travelers and i asked
the cma to review the issue of
exploitative behavior in the private
testing market
this review reported last week and i'm
looking into what further action we can
take
and i can also update honourable members
that on top of these measures we'll be
publishing a new framework for
international travel and my right
honourable friend the transport
secretary will be announcing more
details ahead of the formal review point
on the first of october
thanks to the defensive we've built
we've been able to remove many of the
regulations that have governed our daily
lives rules that were unprecedented yet
necessary
and our plan shows how we'll be removing
more of these powers while maintaining
those that are essential for our
response
this includes expiring more of the
powers in the corona virus act
so for example the those powers
directing to temporary closure of
educational institutions
the remaining provisions will be those
that are critical to the government's
response to the pandemic for example
making sure that the nhs is properly
resourced and supporting statutory sick
pay for those who are self-isolating
mr speaker the plan before the house
today is our plan a a comprehensive plan
to steer this country through the autumn
and winter
but we've seen how quickly this virus
can adapt and change so we have prepared
a plan b
over contingency measures that we can
call upon only if they are needed and
supported by the data to prevent
unsustainable pressure on the nhs
these measures would be
communicating clearly and urgently to
the public the need for caution
legally mandating face coverings in
certain settings
and whilst we're not going ahead with
mandatory vaccine owning covert status
certification now we'll be holding that
power in reserve
as well as these three steps
we'd contin we'd consider a further
measure of asking people to work from
home if they can for a limited time if
that is supported by the data
any responsible government must prepare
for all eventualities and although these
measures are not an outcome that anyone
wants it's one that we need to be ready
for just in case
mr speaker
ever since we published our roadmap to
recovery seven months ago we've been
carefully but cautiously getting this
nation closer to normal life
now we've come so far we've achieved so
much we must stay vigilant as we
approach this critical chapter
so that we can protect the progress that
we have all made together i commend this
statement to the house
shout out secretary of state jonathan
ashworth grateful um uh uh mr speaker
and i thank the secretary of state for
advanced site of his state if his
statement and i like the secretary of
state want to extend my condolences to
the prime minister and the wider johnson
family at this at this difficult time
now infection levels today are actually
higher than they were at this time last
year so the test of his plan a and his
plan b
is whether we can push infections down
minimize sickness and save lives
keep schools open
protect care homes maintain access to
all care
in the national health service and avoid
a winter lockdown
he's talked about a plan b
can he tell us what level of infection
and hospitalizations does he think would
trigger plan b
now yesterday downing street briefed
about a lockdown as last resort
what then if i may put it like this is
first resort in combating the virus to
avoid a loca to avoid a winter lockdown
and will he rule out today
local and regional lockdowns like we saw
in my city of leicester or in bolton and
parts of west yorkshire last year
now on vaccination uh last night we had
confirmation of vaccine program for
children we welcome that and we support
that and he's now confirmed a booster
job as well uh we again welcome that and
support that
but how will they boost vaccines
in those areas of the country where
vaccine take up remains relatively low
for example bradford the second doses
are running around 65 percent
wolverhampton 65 burnley 69 my own city
of leicester 61
what support will be made available for
those areas and others so they can boost
vaccine take up
vaccinating children is often justified
in my view wrongly on the basis of its
impact on adults and the wider
transmission but children and young
people would actually benefit further if
vaccination rates were increased amongst
adults but amongst younger adults 25 to
30 year olds it's running around 55 on a
second dose 30 to 35 year old 68
so what is he going to do
to vaccinate more younger adults what
campaign is he going to run to get those
vaccination rates
up
and what is the plan for those who are
immunosuppressed who have shielded
throughout this crisis
one example there are 1 million cancer
patients who can't produce an immune
response to vaccines will they be
offered prophylactic antibody treatment
that are now available or will they be
expected to shield further throughout
the winter and on flu his rights to
raise flu and seasonal viruses but he
will know that the australian flu season
has been minimal it's good for australia
obviously but that impacts the ability
to collect samples to make an
appropriate vaccine for the strain that
might hit us is he confident of the
effectiveness of the flu vaccine to
match this year's strain now secondly on
test and trace and wider diagnostics
again flu rsv we're likely to see more
common colds and coughs
these are viruses with overlapping
symptoms to covert
and there are also an increasing range
of symptoms associated with covid as
well will you look at multiplex testing
so as well as diagnosing a uh a covid
whether you are covered positive it also
diagnoses flu and rsv the academy of
medical sciences have recommended this
and he said that pcr testing will
continue free of charge through autumn
and winter i think that's the first time
my time frame has been put on free pcr
testing is he suggesting we'll be moving
to a different system for pcr testing
from next spring and summer where
perhaps people will be expected to pay
for a test could he just clarify the
government's thinking for testing next
spring and summer from the rest of the
year now of course isolation rules have
changed understandably but we still
still need tracing systems so the local
authorities get the tracing uh the
resources they need to do contact racing
and for those people who need to isolate
still the local authorities have more
money in their funds to pay isolation
payments because we know that people who
are
low paid on zero hours contracts and so
on it's such a struggle for them to
isolate themselves
he's talked about mask wearing and
working from home but he's not talked
about
ventilation so much because we know the
virus is airborne we know that
workplaces actually have legal standards
about the quantity of fresh air
and purified there that is appropriate
so what is he going to do to drive up
ventilation in workplaces and support
public buildings to install the relevant
kits air purification kits so people are
not breathing in
contaminate contaminated air effectively
he didn't mention social care one of the
most devastating consequences of failing
to protect care homes of not putting
that protective ring around them was the
tragic number of deaths in care homes
the infection control fund currently
ends at the uh the 30th september will
that infection control fund for social
care be extended and finally on vaccine
passports can he just clarify what
exactly is the position of the
government now and what the government
is actually proposing and what the
government will ask the house to decide
on sky he said he's not ruling it out
and the bbc said he was ruling it out
he's now saying they will keep it in
reserve and yesterday downing street
said vaccine passports are a first line
of defense against a winter wave what
exactly is the position rather than
zigzagging all over the place on faxing
passports can we just get clarity and
can the house make a final decision on
whether we think vaccine passports are
appropriate intervention or not
thank you mr speaker the normal
gentleman's number of questions let me
just quickly plow through them on a plan
a which i've you made clear that is
absolutely our focus that is the
situation we're in
vaccines remain a critical part of it
testing and surveillance can i thank the
royal war gentleman for support of our
vaccine program including his comments
yesterday um but he asked me also about
the your plan b i think is absolutely
right the government has a contingency
plan
and the the the trigger so to speak uh
for plan b would as i've mentioned in my
speech would be to to look carefully at
the pressures on the nhs and if at any
point we deemed it to be unsustainable
so if there's a significant rise in
hospitalization that we thought they
were unsustainable then we would look
carefully
if we need to take any of those plan b
measures they would be informed by the
data of course we would come to the
house at the time and uh and
and take the uh make the appropriate
response um it's it's really important i
think uh to just emphasize uh because we
can't do enough the importance of of
vaccines and as i said uh mr speaker we
we now know uh from the data just
yesterday for the ons that in the first
half this year 99 of those people uh
that died from covet 19 sadly um
were not vaccinated and it just shows us
that really highlights the importance of
vaccination the right old gentleman
asked about people that are
immunosuppressed
uh he will see that in the plan we
publish today we we talk
we set out uh you know more details
around that including uh treatments that
either currently available or treatments
that may soon be available i've
mentioned the work of the antivirals
task force it's doing great work and uh
there are a number of um
possible new treatments and it's
something the uk is very engaged in also
for those immunosuppressed that can take
the vaccine the iran honorable gentleman
will know that i think it was just last
week that we announced a a third dose as
part of the primary treatment uh and
that again is um a reminder of the
action that we're taking that our
advisors are uh constantly uh looking at
to see what more
we can do the ironman gentleman asked
about the flu uh risk and it is a
significant risk this year high a really
significant risk not least because uh
for reasons that we're all familiar with
there wasn't much flu last year there's
a lot less sort of natural immunity
around in our communities and the flu
vaccine itself
is it does have uh uh flu vaccine for
not just in the uk but being deployed
across europe has less efficacy than
normal
but it is still effective it is still a
very worthwhile uh vaccine and that's
why we will try to be trying to maximize
uptake as i said that with the biggest
rollout program and communications
program this country has ever seen for
the flu vaccine um on diagnosis the
radon gentleman made a good point in
that that is something that we're
looking at with you covered and the flu
uh jointly uh on testing arrangements i
think i've set them out clearly mr
speaker in our statement we have no
plans to change the current arrangements
but of course we constantly keep that
under review but as long as uh those
tests are needed and and needed
available free for the public year that
that will be the case but as i say we
will keep it under review and then in
terms of infection control in um
in social care settings uh there is a
substantial amount of funding available
uh we have already uh made available for
this year this financial year some 34
billion pounds of funding in total for
nhs and the care system for a lot of
these extra measures and that is a
huge amount of funding much of it is
going uh towards essential work like
affection control and we will make sure
that what is needed is there and his
last question around um
vaccinoni certification i think i've
made their government's position clear
it is not something it is not something
that we are implementing we're not going
ahead with any plans uh for that i think
for any government to do something like
that it would be such a big decision uh
and it would have to be backed up by the
evidence and the data that that evidence
is not there and i hope that it will
never be that situation but to keep it
in reserve is the right thing to do
tell the committee jeremy help
i welcome this announcement particularly
on boosters
yesterday i asked the vaccines minister
when we were going to hear about
boosters just 15 hours later the
secretary of state is making a statement
it's almost as if the government is
listening and it's very very good news
can i ask the secretary of state though
nowhere wants to get back to normal more
quickly than the nhs itself
will he commit that the backlog in
mental health treatment will be treated
every bit as seriously as the backlog in
physical health and in particular that
the nhs and the government will continue
to adhere to the mental health
investment standard which says that
mental health spending will increase at
a higher rate than overall nhs spending
particularly when it comes to the extra
money coming from the levy because
parity of esteem is supported on all
sides of the house legislated for in
this house and there is a lot of worry
in the mental health world that the
money from the levy will not reflect the
needs of mental health backlog
mr speaker i mean first of all i i
always listen to the former health
secretary he's always got some uh
good advice and i'm pleased to think
that he thinks the government's uh
moving quickly uh on the on the backlog
and mental health he's absolutely right
to raise this issue the government is
absolutely committed to a parity of
esteems not just in law it's in our
manifesto and i want to take this
opportunity to reassure everyone who's
particularly uh concerned may have
raised this issue with my right
honourable friend that that commitment
remains and also this new funding that
will go in over the next three years to
help deal with the backlog it absolutely
includes mental health funding yeah
snp spokesperson martin day
thank you mr speaker may i start by
extending my condolences and those of my
party to the prime minister on his
family bereavement i'm also grateful to
the secretary of state for advanced site
of his statement and i would echo his
call for vigilance and the importance of
getting vaccinating
with regards to covert data it has shown
how few deaths between january and july
were amongst the fully vaccinated and
clearly demonstrates the effect of
vaccines and driving down deaths a
message which we have to all take home
to our constituencies
now with winter approaching and more
favorable conditions for transmission of
the virus to take place it is welcome
that we are extending vaccines to our
younger citizens and also the news on
booster vaccines however what more does
a minister think can be done to
encourage the million people over the
age of 60 who have not yet been double
vaccinated to become so
the winter will be a difficult time for
many people in the uk with the annual
flu wave potentially coinciding with
another covered wave the disruption this
will entail immediately after the end of
furlough and the universal credit uplift
coming as it does at a time of rising
fuel bills
why is the uk government insisting on
ending two of the key measures
supporting people through the pandemic
shortly before a potentially difficult
winter month for millions
and it is absolutely essential that
self-isolation remains affordable
finally mr speaker the uk government has
cancelled a contract with vaccine
company valniva which was set to produce
vaccines for the uk and scotland at its
livingston facility on these benches we
would be very grateful if the secretary
of state could provide an explanation as
to why this deal was cancelled before
the trials were even completed and
threatening jobs in scotland
mr speaker first of all can i thank the
hong kong general for raising again in
this house the importance of vaccines i
agree with him wholeheartedly in what he
said
about vaccines and he's right to think
about what more can be done to encourage
people particularly older people over
60s uh you throughout the uk to take up
more uh
of this offer for vaccination uh there
are a number of things being done i know
both here in england and in scotland as
well uh to focus on this but including
making greater use of family gps and and
also just taking the time that is
necessary to
allay people's concerns where they are
hesitant and to allow them to speak to
the clinicians that they want access to
to give them that comfort and that work
will continue and we're constantly
looking for
newer and perhaps even better ways to do
that on universal credit when the the
government announced that increase it
was made clear that it was uh temporary
and i think you know being temporary at
some point it has to come to an end i
think the time for that is now as our
economy has thankfully started to reopen
um the the the the the the um
availabilities of jobs is increasing
economic growth has come back i think
this is the right time to do it but also
to continue to provide the type of
financial support that is absolutely
necessary such as for those that
self-isolate which is something i
touched on earlier and then lastly the
honourable gentleman asked me about uh
val neva
i should be careful uh what i say there
is a commercial contract but what i it
might be helpful him
for the honourable gentleman to know
that i have been in
in touch with the health minister in
scotland and he is fully aware of the
situation and we will remain in dialogue
mr mcvay
apologies thank you mr speaker
given that the number of hospital beds
has fallen by over 6 000 since the
pandemic figures sent to me by his
department will the minister assure me
that proper additional capacity will be
back built back into the nhs as part of
his plan
rather than resorting to hugely damaging
lockdowns and restrictions
yeah i thank my right-hand for that
question and uh and she's right to raise
the importance of capacity in the nhs
and she will know that the the reason
for the falling capacity in the first
place is to control the spread of the
virus to make sure that those in
hospital that by
that are naturally vulnerable in any
case are protected uh from the virus and
at the moment hospitals will have what
are referred to as sort of green
channels and red channels trying to
segregate between those that have the
virus and not and this is something i
can assure her that the nhs is keeping
under review and would like to get rid
of this uh segregation as soon as
possible when it does it will increase
capacity
thank you mr speaker and what are the
secretary of state's plans for
communications with immunocompromised
people who do not yet know how effective
the vaccine is for them as the shadow
minister said this group accounts for
13.1
of deaths within the fully vaccinated
population
despite making up less than one percent
of the general population and does he
not agree that we should be advising
them not to return to unsafe workplaces
until we know more
the honourable ladies right to raise
this is such an important issue and that
is why
we have throughout the pandemic
offered advice and given guidance
through clinicians working with the nhs
for those that are immunocompromised and
that is constantly updated as the the
nature of the covert thread is is
constantly changing and and and where we
get advised to take further action so a
moment of government speak i refer to
for for certain people that immuno
compromised but they can take the
vaccine we receive clear advice
that the antibody response from two
doses uh wasn't enough most cases that
there should be a third dose as part of
a primary uh course and and that is why
we accepted that advice and acted on it
me immediately i think that that
affected about
thousand uh people in that category but
we will continue to keep it under review
and do whatever we can
brian blade
thank you mr speaker i welcome the
government's rethink on vaccine
passports and i hope it prestages a move
to trusting people more
to make decisions for themselves the
secretary of state will know there is
evidence now that people returning from
green list and ambulance countries over
the summer
actually had a lower level of covert
than people who stayed here uh during
the summer uh does he accept that makes
a very powerful case for getting rid of
the day two pcr tests for people
returning from those countries
mr speaker my right on my friend is
right to to raise this and uh it's the
reason why we have constantly kept our
travel rules uh relating to covid uh
under review um and in my statement
earlier you may have heard i refer to a
set of changes that we are looking to
make very soon and my honourable friend
the transport secretary will be bringing
forward those changes to the house as
soon as he possibly can diane abbott
thank you mr speaker the secretary of
state quite correctly
is urging people to get vaccinated
he will be aware that there are certain
ethnic minorities that have relatively
low vaccine take up sadly and we see
this for instance
in my own borough of hackney is there
anything that he has considered that the
government could do nationally to
support outreach to ethnic minority
communities
the right honourable lady makes a really
important point we want everyone to take
up their offer of a vaccine and and
she's right to point out the disparity
in take-up based on certain communities
i think the the good news is we have
certainly noticed partly i think there's
a response uh to
government action and some fantastic
people especially you know i've come
across for example in london in the
public health uh
working for public health england that
have worked with reached out to
communities to increase uptake and we
have seen a significant increase in
uptake in the communities that she
refers to
over the summer but that's work that
continues and it remains a priority
robert halford
um thank you mr speaker i welcome the
um the boosterism program for the
vulnerable that my
friend has set out today but can i just
ask him about this vexed issue about
parental consent because the nhs website
states that it would be rarely
appropriate or safe for a child to
consent without parents
involvement and the parents concern must
be sought prior to vaccination so can my
right offend confirm whether it's the
intention to follow this advice and if
not on what legal basis does that
decision be made because the gillick uh
late and later case law was intended for
a far more narrow set of circumstances
and a mass role out of treatment to
otherwise healthy children so if he is
going to make the decision to ensure
credibility in the system there has to
be parental
consent yeah mr speaker i would like to
reassure my right honourable friend uh
on this in the the the first the legal
basis that we are falling for
vaccinations in particular in this case
for child vaccinations is the the one
that's been set out since the 1980s
under and been used by uh
applied by successive uh governments for
all child vaccinations and the way the
the offer of a covered 19 vaccine will
work will be no different to the current
processes deployed and that does require
in the first distance to ask parents uh
for their consent and i'm told by the
school age immunization service these
are the sort of specialists within the
school system that work on child
vaccination that in the vast majority of
cases uh that that is that there's no
there's no dispute between what a parent
decides and what the child might decide
and that's the the and it sort of just
works quite uh
normally in that way where there is a
difference of opinion perhaps so between
the the parent and the child then the
school-age immunization service would
try to uh reach a consensus bring both
parties together and only in those rare
situations where they cannot reach a
consensus
then the process that is followed uh
called guilty competence is a process by
which it would have to be determined if
the child in question is competent
enough to make decisions regarding their
own health and in general i am told that
the older the child the more likely
there is to be a decision that they are
competent enough but i can stress that
this is the process followed for for
decades now and under successive
governments and we won't be
changing that process
thank you mr speaker
we know that the
ring of protection
that the government spoke of last year
was non-existent and left many
vulnerable adults in social care exposed
to infection and so can the secretary of
state say what uh resources specifically
are going to be made available for care
homes this winter
so
so that we can ensure that they have the
staffing levels that they need and to
prevent the sort of
devastating infection rates that we saw
last year
mr speaker i can tell the honourable
gentleman that we have already
planned to spend an additional 34
billion pounds
this year
on both nhs and care homes
helping to pay for additional measures
such as infection control measures some
additional staffing costs and we
constantly keep that under review
angela richardson
speaker can i echo the comments my right
onward friendly constituency neighbor
the chair of the health select committee
made and raising concerns about mental
health i'm dealing with a constituent at
the moment who's been sectioned under
the mental health act but there were no
beds in surrey and she's been had had to
be moved to kent um would my
honourable friend look at increasing
capacity in those most severe cases so
that families don't have to undertake
the journey in what is already a
difficult set of circumstances for them
mr speaker my honourable friend is right
to raises it's a very difficult
situation and of course i think what
everyone in this house understands and
it is one of the reasons why we are
increasing capacity there is new funding
and support and it's something that
remains a priority monero wills very
much mr speaker could i start by
extending my condolences and on behalf
of my party their condolences to the
prime minister and his family today
mr speaker children and young people
have done everything that's been asked
of them through this pandemic as have
their parents yet children have paid a
high price in terms of lost learning and
in particular their mental health
yet they've been an afterthought from
government for government throughout
it's all very well announcing today that
the power to close schools in the
coronavirus act will be expired it makes
a great great headline but the health
secretary is well aware that power was
never used previously to close schools
just guidance from the education
secretary so will he give pupils and
parents across the country a cast iron
guarantee today that his government will
not close schools again this winter yeah
yeah
mr speaker i think the honourable lady
will agree that we are as a country in a
much better place today with cobin than
we saw even at the start of this year
and that is down to many factors a
number of those i referred to in my
statement uh but i believe with the
measures we set out today that we
couldn't be confident that our children
will not have to go again
through the kind of disruption that
they've seen in the last couple of years
david davis
the distinguishing characteristic of the
coronavirus emergency act was not so
much the new powers which already
existed in the civil contingency and
other acts but the fact that the
ministers were not required to get them
approved by parliament before
implementation and it's one of the
reasons for the poor quality of some of
the decisions taken in the last year can
you give an undertaking that any new
regulations and indeed any regulations
he retains will be put to the house
before implementation including uh
vaccine certification if the
government's unwise enough to pursue
that course
mr speaker i can tell my right old
friend that when when the government any
government makes decisions that has such
an impact on on people's liberties even
if those re those decisions are made for
all the right reasons
in this case of course to deal with this
pandemic
then it should be working with the house
and working uh with colleagues and any
measures uh that are significant of
course they should come to the
government will come to the house and
seek to vote for the house dan mcphillia
thank you mr speaker the secretary of
state talked about international work
and unless we tackle this across the
world we're going to be in a pandemic
forever so when he was at the g20 and he
shared with other countries what we're
doing to help tackle it internationally
could he please share with the house
what's being done to tackle vaccination
rates across the globe
i can tell the honourable lady that
there was significant discussion around
this with my g20 colleagues uh but not
all of them have um let's say behaved in
exact in the same way as the uk in in
offering uh donations to poorer
countries of vaccines the honourable
lady will know that we are committed to
a hundred million doses uh to offering
those to international friends and that
already we have provided or donated 9.2
million doses most of those through the
kovacs program we've remained committed
to that program and one of the things
that we are trying to do internationally
including through the foreign secretary
is to encourage more countries to both
honor their commitments to kovacs and
those that haven't joined the kovacs
commitment to to come forward and help
in that way dean russell
thank you speaker um
across watford we are served by some
amazing gp gt surgeries including the
mana view practice and their team but i
am hearing from constituents that some
gp surgeries are still not opening their
doors to do face-to-face appointments
and uh would i could i ask if you would
agree with me that actually we should
encourage those gp surgeries to start
opening up to help with the backlog and
help see people face to face
yes i agree with my my honourable friend
mr speaker he's right to raise this that
i think everyone can understand why
during the height of the pandemic
gps couldn't provide access in the
normal way but we are way past that now
life is starting to return almost back
to complete normal and as that is
happening it should be happening in our
gp surgeries too and more gps should be
offering face-to-face access and we tend
to do a lot more about it
and about that
mr speaker secretary of state rightly
speaks of the importance of vaccines and
valniva in my livingston constituency is
playing a crucial role in the global
fight against covert and have worked
incredibly hard to augment and adapt
their work
on a vaccine as new variants of emerged
as requested by his uk government so mr
speaker you can imagine dear shock and
mine that their contract to produce a
hundred million vaccines was cancelled
with very little notice or consultation
to compound that shock there appears to
be little clarity and reasoning and
whilst i won't repeat the rumors printed
in the media does the health secretary
not agree that this is a shocking way to
treat a company working tirelessly on a
vaccine and when he meet with me to
ensure the future of the site its work
and its work workers are secure and
rethink this disastrous decision
mr speaker i have say honorably i don't
agree with her the uh
there are commercial reasons uh that we
have cancelled the contract but what i
can tell her is that it was also clear
to us that the the vaccine in question
that the company was developing would
not get approval by the mhra here in the
uk and obviously she is not recommending
that we administer vaccines that don't
get approval i do understand her point
about livingston and the factory in
livingston and that is very important uh
to the uk government of course of the
scottish government and that is
something that we will be working
together on to see what more we can do
dr luke evans
speaker clarification and a request on
the clarification i welcome the boosters
could he clarify for people who've had
either the astrazeneca or the pfizer
will they be having the same vaccine or
mixing a vaccine and a request one of
the slowest things when it comes to
dealing with the pfizer vaccination is
the 15 minute wait you have to sit
through to see you don't have a reaction
we now should have the data will you ask
the nhs to look whether this could be
removed to relieve some of the pressure
on those delivering the vaccines over
the winter
and mr speaker so on the booster program
uh everyone will
on that program will be offered either
the pfizer vaccine or half a dose of the
modern vaccine i think in the vast vast
majority of cases it will be the pfizer
uh vaccine and um
in terms of um
the uh
the data that's now available on that
15-minute wait we are analyzing that and
see if it makes uh if we can make any
difference to the way we administer
vaccines jack trump
um mr speaker jane roach from erdington
lost her father to covid and then five
days later lost her sister to covid
they led the
hundreds of families who came to london
last week down the memorial wall
calling with one voice for the promised
inquiry to take place
they are frustrated
because they want not just for their
families to know why they died but for
no one else to die as a consequence of
mistakes made
when will the secretary of state and the
prime minister
agree to honor the pledge that has been
made to meet with coveted families for
justice because they have a right to be
heard at the next stages
mr speaker the honourable gentleman is
right to raise the concerns of jane and
many others up and down the country and
express her frustration in the way that
he did
i am certain mr speaker that when this
inquiry gets going that people like jane
and many others will have the
opportunity to to set out their views
welcome
mr speaker mr speaker first of all thank
you for granting the statement last
night i think it was important the house
heard an early opportunity the
government's decision um regretfully
there were one or two inadvertent
inaccuracies in some responses to the
questions but i'm very pleased to say
having raised those with the minister uh
who i respect greatly uh a correction
has either been made or is going to be
made very quickly and i think that's
admirable
from the department that they sought to
put the record straight at a very early
opportunity can i ask the secretary of
state in his statement he said that
regular
asymptomatic testing of those in
education will continue in the coming
months now my understanding was there
was to be a review at the end of
september about regularly testing
children that have no symptoms is that
still going to continue
my view is that we shouldn't be
regularly testing children who have no
symptoms only those that have symptoms
that is also the view of the royal
college of pediatrics and child health
so can i urge the secretary of state to
drop regular asymptomatic testing of
children i think that will be good for
their education and good for their
mental health
mr speaker
the my right on my friend raised the
issue of uh yesterday's statement and uh
i'm pleased he's he's accepted that
the the vaccines minister had
inadvertently i think my royal friend
was referring to whether we had the
department had received the advice from
jcvi on boosters and the vaccine
minister was not aware at the time he
was making statement that we had
actually received it and as he says it
was inadvertent and the vaccine minister
has put a letter of correction or has
done an electoral collection which i
think is going in the library of the
house uh today um that on asymptomatic
testing of a school children that is
planned to continue for this month
whether we continue beyond that
we i'm not aware of a final decision
that's been made and that is something
that my department consults with with
the department for education but the
general point that he's making is that
we should end this
as soon as we can
and especially if we if we believe it's
not making much of a difference of
course we keep that under review and if
we continue with it it must be supported
by the evidence
the emancipal
thank you very much mr speaker the
secretary of state in rural there's been
a 13 increase in one week
in levels uh of infection and sadly four
people died uh in hospital after a
period of there being very very few
deaths indeed so we're at a much higher
level of
infection rates can he tell the house
what level of deaths the government will
be prepared to
accept from covid before they think
of taking measures to try to prevent the
ongoing spread
mr speaker of course no one wants to see
any death from any disease including
kovid
but i i think that as we've learned more
about covid i think everyone understands
that it's it's not uh you're completely
preventable but it's our vaccines uh
that are making a difference in will uh
and across the country i mean no level
of deaths i would describe as acceptable
uh the job of the government is to keep
that at an absolute minimum but not just
covert deaths we also have to be alive
to death from cancer from uh from
heart disease and things and she will
know when we had
the height of the restrictions many
people were suffering in other ways
because they weren't able to go to the
nhs and we have to keep that top of our
mind too
it's been very tough for all health
professionals so will the secretary of
state wholeheartedly condemn the abuse
which some gps have been suffering
recently and if vulnerable people are
unable to get through on the telephone
to their surgery is it the clinical
commissioning group or the department
that should step in and try and sort
that out
yeah i absolutely would join my
honourable friend in condemning anyone
that gives abuse to our fantastic gps up
and down the country and uh
and if someone cannot get through to the
the gp the answer is they should try
certainly with their clinical
commissioning group first if for any
reason that doesn't work then uh please
come across to the department and
consult ministers
thank you very much mr speaker the
secretary of state has not delivered a
concrete plan today no real clarity on
thresholds for further lockdowns or
details of what draconian and
unnecessary powers in the corona virus
act he wants to hold on to can he at
least see when the soon to expire act
will be back before this house for
revolt
can i suggest mr speaker that the
honourable lady reads the plan before
she comments on it
steve bryant
speaker i welcome much of what is a
sensible plan today from the secretary
of state although i do have a creeping
feeling we're preparing to treat flu
like covid more than the other way
around but before we start extend the
vaccine program and boosters can i ask
the secretary of state to get a grip on
a creeping issue which is people who've
had one vaccination in england and
another one in scotland all the other
way around the two systems are not
talking to each other and they're then
not getting the benefits of being fully
jabbed so we need to deliver for those
who've done what we've asked them to do
before we deliver vaccines to others
my honourable friend is is absolutely
right to to raise this and i have people
in my own family who've had that very uh
issue and uh it is something that i know
the vaccines minister uh is looking at
but i also have discussed it with the
health minister in scotland and we are
working to see what more we can do
dave dugan thank you mr speaker as we go
into another winter place placing a
community's welfare in the hands of
health and social care staff can the
secretary of state reflect on the fact
that in england the three percent nhs
pay rise does not marry up well to the
four percent back dated in scotland why
will the secretary of state not place
the same esteem on health and social
care staff in england as we do in
scotland
mr speaker when it came to the pay raise
the honourable gentleman referred to we
accepted the recommendation
of the independent pay review body and i
think that was the right thing to do
greg clark
is
aware that the likely course of the
pandemic is that more and more people
vaccinated or not are likely to be
infected by covet but the levels of
protection from the vaccines will keep
them from serious disease
so will he say something about the
triggers for any future
lockdown or other restrictions and
confirm that the expected increase in
the transmission of kovid will not be
among them
mr speaker my right or my friend is is
right about the of course the importance
of uh vaccines and uh in terms of uh any
potential triggers and
i think one thing i would highlight mr
speaker that i haven't mentioned uh uh
so far uh today is is the importance of
uh being
on guard against a your future variants
but especially if there is ever a
variant that is a let's say a vaccine
escape variant no one can rule that out
uh that is why our surveillance system
is so important but in in that situation
i think the government would uh have to
take further action we couldn't say what
that action would be today but that is
the kind of risk that we need to be on
guard
in whole we have the second highest
rates of covered infection in the
country and in one of the wards in my
constituency only 51
coverage of second doses of the covered
vaccination of course the secretary of
state said the national average is 81
so this figure it seems to me goes to
the heart of the problems we have with
regional inequalities and health
inequalities and i'd like to know what
the secretary of state is going to do to
make sure that we maximize the number of
people in hull who receive the
vaccination and we don't have people in
hull left behind in the recovery
mr speaker of course no one should be
left behind wherever they are
in the uk
the the
the differential take-up of the vaccine
can be based on a number of factors but
there's definitely a difference in age
groups uh for example and and so what we
are trying to do working with the nhs is
we tailor our message
about trying to convince people about
the benefits of the vaccine here to
those respective age groups and and we
also try to on a localized basis if the
honourable lady has any particular
suggestions around hull would be more
than happy to listen to her
so doesn't sway
he retains all the powers of the 1984
public health act which were used to
take away our liberties without
parliamentary prior authority will he
undertake to review
and to give us a new public health act
mr speaker we we keep all uh rules and
uh acts uh under review at all times
that bloodshot
he will know from the discussions he scr
he describes with international
colleagues that while travel in the rest
of europe has recovered to 60
of pre-curved levels it's a fraction of
that here so when will he scrap the
outdated unnecessary and hugely
expensive travel testing regime save
what's left of an industry and end the
situation where foreign travel has once
again become the preserve of the rich
mr speaker i'd say two things for the
ride all the gentlemen first of all that
it is important that we have a system of
surveillance especially around uh
variants across the world there are
different ways to do that uh we've
chosen a particular path at the moment
but it is important to have that
surveillance i hope he agrees and as i
alluded to earlier in my statement we
are planning to make some changes around
the travel regime and my right
honourable friend of transport secretary
will come to the house as soon as he's
ready
mr speaker time and time again i'm
hearing from constituents of mine that
they can't get face-to-face appointments
with gps i know they're under immense
pressure um further to the answer uh my
right honourable friend gave to my uh my
friend from watford would he be able to
elaborate on what work he and his
department are doing to encourage gps to
give face-to-face appointments to those
individuals who need them
yes i can mr speaker and that
again it is a very important issue we
are working with the bma the nhs and
other uh in important um organizations
uh on this and uh there are a number of
things that think that we we can do but
we are trying to
reach do so by agreement at this point
uh but he's right to raise this issue
and uh as i said earlier it is a high
time that gp started uh operating uh in
the way that they did before the
pandemic and offering face-to-face
appointments that everyone who would
like one
another
mr speaker in the health secretary's
statement the first matter he mentioned
is the importance of vaccines and but we
know that 40 of the world's population
has been single vaccinated against covid
but only 1.8 of those in low-income
countries have been vaccinated and are
not on track to vaccinate their
populations until 2023. to be frank mr
speaker this government has previously
taken a a dangerous route in their
international policies like their
anti-refugee bill for an insular britain
so my question is will the government
commit to ensuring the uk plays its part
in vaccinating the poorest nations in
the world firstly to save lives and
secondly to avoid the potential
emergence of further covered variations
mr speaker we are more than playing our
part
you murrayman
mr speaker thank you very much indeed i
know that the international travel
sector will welcome the framework given
that it will come out in the first of
october will that give colleagues and
indeed select committees the opportunity
to feed in their ideas on behalf of
their constituents and will he entertain
the idea of moving to lateral flow tests
which are cheaper and then only the
small proportion of positive cases would
then need to take up a pcr test
mr speaker i know these are important
issues for the house but particularly
for my honourable friend the chair of
the transport select committee uh i
don't want to preempt the the statement
of my right honourable friend the
transport secretary uh but i believe
that uh that when he makes that
statement that my honourable friend will
be pleased
uh alice carmichael
very much martin deputy speaker pages 23
to 24 of the ottoman winter plan
specifies that as part of the plan b
the government will introduce vaccine
passports for all night clubs
indoor settings of 500 people or more
which presumably would include this
chamber of 650 members
outdoor settings of a thousand or more
or anywhere which is a very big place
anywhere where there are ten thousand
people
how does the secretary of state square
that
with his assertion in replying to the
shadow secretary of state that the
evidence on the usefulness of vaccine
passports is just not there if the
evidence is not there why are they part
of the plan b
and the government's document also says
that plan b could be brought into force
at very short notice so can he give the
house some assurance that it will not be
without a vote
short questions and short answers
secretary of state mr speaker we have
made huge progress as a country in
fighting this virus and that is why we
don't need certification we don't need
uh the the the issues that the the
the sort of plan b uh issues the
honorable right on the gentleman has
just set out and as i've made clear in
my statement that we once we can keep
other measures in reserve what matters
is what we are actually doing and if we
keep making progress against this virus
in the way that we are we won't need any
of those things he's talked about
jason mccartney thank you madam deputy
speaker it's worth highlighting once
again the latest stats from ons that
show that almost 99 percent of kobe
deaths in the first half of this year
were people who had not received both
doses of the covid19 vaccine that really
does show the importance of our
world-leading vaccination program so can
the secretary of state say that as we
roll out these booster jabs how will he
build on the success of the network of
gp surgeries community pharmacies and
volunteers who have helped roll out in
particular my part of the world all
these covid vaccinations
yes
my animal friend is right to raise this
the booster jabs are going to be hugely
important in maintaining protection and
the the gp networks the nhs vaccination
centers they're all being part of our
planning for this and given that these
are booster jabs i think we can move
much more quickly than we did with the
original doses
emma hardy
deputy speaker parents will have
questions and concerns quite rightly but
can the minister confirm that those
questions and concerns should not be
directed to school staff
or head teachers even if the vaccination
happens to take place within a school
building and instead all questions
related to the vaccination should be
directed to the appropriate medical team
yes
steve baker thank you
speaker uh my honourable friend amongst
other things is keeping kovid's status
certification in reserve he's leaving
mass asymptomatic testing in place
together with contact racing as my
right-hand friend said the public health
powers are still there of course
allowing him to lock us down at the
stroke of his pen without prior votes or
any formal way of justifying the
proportionality of those powers so when
can we expect all of these things to be
dealt with so that we can all have the
certainty that will come from knowing
that we're living with an endemic
disease living with the disease thanks
to the vaccine in the way that we live
with the endemic disease flu so that we
can all get on with our lives
may not agree with every measure that
the government is keeping in place or
set out but i hope i hope he agrees with
me that the
the measures that i've set out around
making sure that we are vaccinating the
public offering vaccines as many people
as possible having some kind of testing
regime
and having some surveillance of the
results of these tests to look out for
any new variants i hope he agrees that
at least those measures are the right
measures and the kind of things that uh
that need to be done as we live with
covert 19.
patricia gibson thank you madam deputy
speaker vaccine passports we were told
by the uk government they were going
ahead then they weren't going ahead then
we were told they're the first they're
still the first line of defense against
the winter wave now the latest position
is they're a definite maybe now this is
dithering we haven't seen since the
great confusion over masquerade which
can be seen if you look around this
chamber how irresponsible does the
secretary of state think
that this dangerous and confused public
message enduring the health pandemic
actually is
madam definitely speak i believe we've
been very clear on this issue
jane hunt
thank you very much madame speaker last
friday leicestershire mps met with nhs
officials locally we were told that
around three quarters of all all in
hospital with covid were not vaccinated
would my right honourable friend agree
with me that if we do not want to be in
lockdown this winter
we should all who can should get the
vaccine especially in leicester where i
now understand that the shadow
minister's earlier comments jacob is
only 61
i i agree madame dev speaker with my
honourable friend there's some six
million adults throughout the uk that
remain unvaccinated and i think we
should all do what we can to at least
encourage them to think about taking the
vaccine not only to protect themselves
but to protect their loved ones rachel
maskel thank you madam deputy speaker
i'm seriously concerned about the hole
in the secretary of state's defense that
taking away contact tracing from public
health teams the data that is coming
through is completely insufficient now
to carry out an effective operation
locally and therefore to lock down the
virus not people in the future will he
look at this and ensure that local
authorities like in york we can have
that zero data so we can get on top of
the contact rating as soon as the data
emerges
madam deaf speaker there
there are measures that when it makes
sense we must remove and and the reason
that we can take a different approach to
contact tracing that we did a few months
ago is
largely down to the high rates of
vaccination we're seeing throughout the
country of course we want them to go
higher but as we vaccinate more it
allows us to start removing these
restrictions these additional costs uh
these burdens on the individual
livelihoods and it is right approach
that i think we take we take a balanced
approach keep increasing vaccination so
we can keep removing other restrictions
simon clark thank you speaker i welcome
the central states statement today can i
just raise the plight of care home
residents many of whom have been kept
apart from their families and loved ones
owing to outbreaks being declared in
their home obviously we need to set a
proportion of balance here but i think
the threshold for intervention by
declaring an outbreak is really quite
low uh could the central state committee
he'll look at this so we can ensure that
people can see their loved ones
throughout the winter ahead
yes ma'am deputy speaker i can give that
commitment to my honourable friend and
also he may be interested to know that
with the booster announcement today that
claire home residents will be an
absolute priority
leila moran madam deputy speaker back in
june the prime minister committed the uk
and other g7 nations to vaccinating the
world by the end of 2022 and i quote to
end this terrible pandemic so can the
secretary of state tell this house how
offering a third vaccine to a fully
vaccinated healthy adult in the uk
before
a first vaccine to a nurse in a lower
income country helps that goal of
vaccinating the world by 2022. yeah yeah
well i'm deputy speaker i do understand
the the point the honourable lady is
making but may i suggest if she hasn't
yet she should read the jcvi's advice on
booster vaccines and i think then she
might be able to better appreciate the
importance of the booster program
dr ben
spencer for speaking and i thank my
writerable friend for his statement
today i think we all hope that plan b
isn't activated but on that can unfollow
up to the rightful friend for turmeric
wells can he lay out exactly what
interstellar pressure means and it is an
assessment of nhs capacity going
forwards over winter where does he see
the bottleneck is it staff is it
medication is it beds and what work is
being done to to enhance that capacity
very good okay
madame deputy speaker what i can tell my
honorable friend that
when i talked earlier about
unsustainable pressure it would be
things like looking at hospital
occupancy looking at the occupancy in
particular in icu
units the admissions of uh vaccinated
individuals versus unvaccinated
individuals and the rate of growth and
admissions i know there's a lot there
but i think it's right that we don't
have any does not want one particular
trigger so we have to take a number of
issues into account but i hope he agrees
the government is right to plan for all
contingencies jim shannon i'm david
schwerken behalf of my part of the dep
can i convey my sincere sympathies to
the prime minister's family in the death
of his mum can also thank the central
state for his statement and efforts on
behalf of us all will the secretary of
state confirm the booster rollout for
over 50s will be managed in line with
the flu job rollout which seems to be
facing some delay and will the
segregated further confirm that
additional funding is being allocated to
gp practices to enable this enhanced
rollout to actually take place thank you
thank you madam speaker yes gps
do get and will get additional funding
to support the vaccination programs
including a flu vaccination program
in terms of um co-administering if
that's what the honourable general's
asking the uh covert vaccine with the
flu vaccine
whilst the jcbi in their opinion has
said that there's no reason why that
shouldn't happen they think that can
work
i think in in practical terms uh mainly
because of the 15 minute wait after a
fisa jab that it will probably happen in
very few cases but regardless of that
the flu vaccination program this year is
also going to be very high priority
where is edwards
thank you madam deputy speaker as my
right on girlfriend has said it's not
been our vaccine program that's enabled
us to get almost back to normal well he
joined me in thanking the staff and the
volunteers at gamston community centre
who've been rolling out the vaccine in
rushcliff and giving my constituents the
best protection they can have against
corona virus
yes sir madame deputy of course i will
at gamston community center and
community centers and uh village halls
and so many other places up and down the
country including of course in her
constituency if they've done an amazing
job and we still need them to help in
our fight against this virus
gary sandberg thank you very much
speaker um as the secretary of state may
know just next door from his own
constituency in birmingham northfield
the vaccine taker has been about 75
but unfortunately in some parts of
birmingham it's been as low as 47
and so will he join me in encouraging
anyone who is hesitant to take the
vaccine to take part in birmingham city
council's quick one-minute survey about
why they have those anxieties because
it's very important that we all
understand where those anxieties lie
because after all the vaccine is pivotal
to our success
okay yes uh madame deputy i will uh join
my honorable friend in encouraging
people to do that i think it would be a
one minute very well spent
jack barrington thank you madam deputy
speaker across so-called trenton
staffordshire uptake of vaccines been
very good and i'd like to thank all
those who've been delivering the vaccine
across stoke-on-trent particularly um
but around for 16 and 17 year olds most
16 17 year olds cannot use currently the
online booking system they have to wait
for their gp to contact them or for one
of the very few walk-in centres so could
my writing friend look at extending that
online booking system to all 16 and 17
year olds
um
we do keep that under review i can tell
my honourable friend at the moment that
we have found for 16 and 17 year olds
that the the quickest way to uh
encourage them to take up the offer is
is through the schools and colleges uh
network and through uh gps in in
particular uh but uh that we do keep it
under review but
he might be interested to know that 16
to 17 year olds i believe the latest uh
numbers are over 54
i think are are vaccinated and there's
progress to be made but it's good
progress so far
james wilde
what the health secretary there setting
out the government's covert plan to mps
as ministers and the nhs prepare for a
likely increase in coronavirus and flu
infections this winter plan a and plan b
plan a is that those over 50 will get a
booster jab the test and trace system
will continue and enhanced public health
advice also first days for 12 to 15 year
olds uh within the next week or so
plan b should things not go quite so
well a bit of a contingency plan sahaja
yoga said it will be triggered by
unsustainable pressure in the nhs
not ruled out masks being uh returned
for a lot of wearing in public spaces
vacating passports and also working from
home um but he is hopeful that plan a uh
will be enough to keep
the covert restrictions in place well
he's confirmed that letters offering
booster jabs will be sent out to all
over 50s from next week and that the
government has accepted that
recommendation for 12 to 15 year olds to
be vaccinated
ministers will continue to suggest face
masks are worn in closed crowded spaces
but it's not a legal requirement
other restrictions will be scaled back
and changes to the traffic light system
will be confirmed on the 1st of october
well let's talk to our political editor
beth rigby uh beth no real big surprises
there um
sadie javed hopeful that
he won't have to implement plan b
yes that's right jane they've just put
out this which is the um the 30-page
cavid uh response autumn and winter plan
which we're we're just going uh through
now but in terms of what the health
secretary had to say there you're
exactly right
the plan is
for a vaccine push and a booster push
this autumn and winter to keep up the
test and trace system to support the nhs
you saw that big announcement on another
5.4 billion to go into the nhs in the
next six months in order to try and deal
with what undoubtedly will be a big win
to crisis when you overlay on the
problem of the flu epidemic this year
given that a lot of people
will have a suppressed immunity because
we were
so locked down in the last winter
the government will also ask the public
to do their bit try to meet outside wear
masks in crowded settings all quite
familiar to us all and the final part of
that five-point plan is to try and
manage borders we'll get more of an
update about what their plans for
international travel will be by the
first
of october but what was more interesting
really because we knew most of that was
the plan b what what is the contingency
plan if things don't go the way the
government uh would like again uh point
one is to ask the public to be even more
cautious so a big communications plan
and then the health sector talked about
mandatory covered passports in certain
settings and we have some detail here
that would be all night clubs indoor
crowded settings with 500 or more
attendees so that could be a musical
concert or maybe going to the theater
outdoor crowded settings with 4 000 or
more attendees such as an outdoor
festival and any setting with 10 000 or
more people such as a law a large sports
event the government goes on to say some
settings would be exempt
and that would be places of communal
worship wedding ceremonies funerals so
on
again that is a contingency plan that
isn't what's going to happen but they
are keeping it on the table
they also talked about compulsory mask
wearing in certain settings didn't go
down well in the comments at all some
heckling there from conservative mps who
didn't like that much at all
and then working from home if you can
from a certain period of time these are
all the contingency plans
and the government also says in this
document it should be possible to handle
a resurgent without lockdowns and social
restrictions of the past but crucially
in this document the government goes on
to say
it doesn't rule out a lockdown or social
restrictions it says the nature of this
virus means it's not possible to give
guarantees government remains committed
to taking action uh wherever whatever
action is necessary to protect the nhs
from being overwhelmed but more harmful
economic and social restrictions would
only be considered as a last resort
that's very different from emphatically
ruling it out so keeping it in
reserve and i can just tell you the
prime minister in cabinet we've just had
a readout of what he told his cabinet
colleagues who uh signed off this plan
uh this morning
he said that since we moved to stepford
july there's been huge progress and he
stressed a desire to see continue uh
bolstering a vaccine program as the fast
line of defense supported by testing
public health advice and a variant
surveillance
system but not ruling out more strict
measures if necessary as we get into the
autumn winter
okay beth thanks very much and we are
going to be hearing from the prime
minister directly this afternoon there's
a news conference live at 3